jimmy's wife jimmy kimmel's wife molly
um i think she's one of the funniest
people i've ever met
i follow her on twitter and she wrote
this is an interesting time of year to
see those of your friends who write
happy new
years plural new years first of all it's
happy new year
so what do i see the next thing i see is
benji writes
happy new years to me happy new years
well he just learned something wrong
benji you don't know it's happy new year
yes it is
no what it's happy new year it's happy
new year's eve
but it's happy new year that's exactly
what it means no
but you know you tell benji something he
just sits and argues with you
doesn't mean it's right molly's right
it's not wrong either no
it it's wrong it's happy new year it's
everybody with a [ __ ]
sense of the english language goes happy
new year
okay all right you're right okay goodbye
goodbye goodbye i'm getting ogida
cut them off cut them off can't take it
i'm trying to help them
just say happy new year from now on okay
not happy new year so you'll
you come off more intelligent okay happy
happy new year howard happy new year
happy new year right don't write happy
new years with an apostrophe
did he write it with an apostrophe yes
that infers possession of the eve
but you didn't say eve you don't have to
oh my gosh oh never mind never mind
okay gotcha happy new years happy new
years to you